有些股票試戳就給你漲停板
有些股票試戳就給你跌停板
一開盤全部不一樣
戳出想要的牌
小哥解讀試戳SOP
好
試戳嚇死人啦
對
開盤呢
休息啦
教各位怎麼來看這個試戳的真假
試戳行情等於開盤行情嗎
戳漲停
然後呢
通常都是要出貨啦
這種就叫做騙婚股
好
開盤前3秒軟掉的就是來騙魂
這招絕招啊
外面要賣3萬8的
今天免費又賣出去
賺到3萬8囉
我會有人身安全
我們很久沒有這樣眼神的交流了
每次都找第三者來
對啊
可是我記得是你跟余辰說
這樣比較輕手
被發現
這真的比較輕鬆
不用準備太多
可是上禮拜因為來的人
又一直出考題Cue
Cue你喔
對
高檔爆炸量
高檔爆炸量 低檔爆炸量
一直Cue你喔
對 所以就覺得
還是讓我們冷靜一下好了
還是跟我在一起輕鬆
跟他在一起會一直考
一直考 一直考 很緊張
對 而且上次我們有提到
我們初戀的那一段
就發現兩檔標股
對 那兩檔
所以我們要靜下心
我們兩個好好聊
好 對
今天聊有點特別
今天真的聊很特別的
好 我們今天呢
我們史上開播以來
第一季怎麼播也播不完的歌
有仇必報
今天只剩下我跟小哥
兩個人屁事密談
為什麼 大家呢
最近股票實在是很熱
可是也開始發現
有一些股票怎麼樣
往上衝的同時呢
有些股票已經好像在做頭
有沒有
所以會很害怕
那你的看盤时间有没有变长了呢
其实赵华每天早上八点半
没事做就一边啃着早餐
一边看什么
看盘前的试戳哦
你有没有发现很有趣
有些股票试戳就给你涨停板
有些股票试戳就给你跌停板
但是好奇怪呢
怎么一开盘全部不一样
你知道试戳是戳好笑戳好玩的吗
今天小哥来告诉你
其实试戳也可以让你赚钱
而且它藏着非常多的密码
我看不懂
先说我看不懂
戳出想要的牌
赌神来了
特异功能人士
上次这张图戳一个方块3
我还特别把那个影片找出来
影片复习一下
截图下来
戳方块3出来
那就变这个顺子
所以就很厉害
很会戳
这个盘浅也一堆人
想要戳出他想要的牌
对
例如说我昨天买一堆
你只會買一堆
假設有個主力買一堆
有個主力買一堆
它盤前就戳掌停
戳掌停
對
戳掌停看起來就喜氣洋洋
我一打開我的下單APP
紅快快
很多就很多
哇 掌停板
趕快去一堆
就一堆完蛋了
就開高手地
怎麼這樣
對啊 所以我們今天就要教各位
怎麼來看這個試戳的真假
對 我覺得很難
而且它8點30分開始戳
戳到8點59分
中间有历经辛勤的起伏
有时候你会看到又涨停又跌停
对啊
它背后都有一些意义
对 好 什么是试错
这也是兆华想问的
为什么想问
因为试错的东西跟开盘常常不一样
这是政府的德政
德政
这德在哪里
为什么
因为有些时候你要买的时候
你不晓得它的价格大概在哪个区间
你就可以从试错
大概看得出来
那你也可以从
考前拆题就对了
对 他先让你
泄题给你
这开盘可能会开在哪里
对
但是呢
你假如没有经过
我们节目的教导
是
你有可能会看错
就是考前给你看一题
考卷全部不一样
考卷不一样
考数学给你国文的题目
太过分
所以既然是得正2015年起
开盘前30分钟会揭露交易资讯
对
本来是觉得得正
因为成交价格
成交价数
最佳五档
其实都会报给你看
但是后来就发现
看不懂
对 因为有些人在玩它
对
在玩它
那我们讲试错时间
证交所是8点半到9点试错
对
那期货是8点半到8点45分
那为什么起到43分呢
因为到43分前
你都可以删
都可以删
所以44分不能删
43分开始到45分不能删
只能看
对 只能看
所以期交所其实8点43分以后
就蛮准的
就蛮准的 戳到那就是那
对 到8点45分
8点43分戳140
8点45分大概就开140
大概是这样
所以大家如果有看我们东生财经的早盘
股东前朝
它就会告诉你现在
期货市戳盘是涨多少都要点
或跌多少都要点
那当然个股的话就不会一档档
报了个股可能就要去你的下滩系统
下滩软体APP
去看你的个股试戳的状况
它会戳到8.59分59秒才开盘
对 没错
所以试戳行情等于开盘行情吗
这个赵华直接跟你说
好像不是
不是喔 不一定喔
有些陷阱在那边
对啊 那所以这个考前猜题
好像没有什么用意耶
有有有
对
我们今天来教各位
小哥解读试戳SOP
通常每天我会去看一下
兼试错涨停跟跌停的股票
先看最极端的
涨停跟跌停
一两块也不用看了
平盘附近震荡小哥
先不理他
试错涨停的
涨很多的
或是大涨
大涨的
我检查有没有隔日冲筹码
短线课在里面
短线课
你检查久了你就知道
有哪些分点专门在玩试错的
那等一下要公布吗
我会有人身安全
以后出门可能会有黑衣人在后面
我会害怕
所以我们不会公布分点
请大家自己去找
其实软体其实会有隔日冲
很多软体都有
有隔日冲的
假如试错又涨停的
反而容易开高走低
就等于是一个诱骗的手法
诱骗的手法
希望你来买
他要出货给你
要出货给你
那假如试错上涨
假如主力有在买的
那这个试错上涨不能涨太多
不能涨太多啊
涨太多
主力要买
它不一定要戳那么高啊
多少算多
你假如涨到8 9% 10%的
那一种除非它可能就今天真的涨停了
它就非买不可
它非买不可
有那种非买不可
可能昨天涨停
今天涨停
明天涨停
永远都在涨停
对 非买不可
那一种呢
它可能就真的上涨
好 所以试错可能涨个4 5%
对
那检查有主力筹码
开盘应该就会涨了
假如是波段主力的
那就是继续涨
所以要检查筹码
光看表面看不出来
看不出来
你光看现行看不出来
好
这个是试戳上涨的话
我们的检查SOP
对
好
我们来举个例子
举例说明
来吧
这昨天的
好
最新的
7月14号
对
我有赚到这一档
你有赚到这一档
对
就是你把它戳起来的
不是
我不是那种人
因为这个一开盘
有没有看到
8点半开始
一律戳停
戳到8点59分52秒
还是涨停
59分52秒
剩8秒钟
剩下59分57秒
才三单
原本1500张
三到剩314张
这5秒你也看得出来
这5秒少了1200张
我看少了
假的
所以开盘架我有空到
所以你是在试错的时候
先把有涨停或跌停的
先塞出来对不对
因为它是一路都挂涨停
所以你就眼睛盯着它
是涨停我就不空你
不是涨停我就要空你了
最后五秒钟发现真的删单了
真的删单了
那假的
看起来它迫不及待的要出货
骗了一堆人上车
而且他们家的网路都很好
對啊
他們家都不怕停電
下單有時候網路會順斷一下
他們家都不怕網路在59分55秒的時候
突然斷電
然後街上的時候全部成交對 一開盤哇塞 1500張全部成交成交又漲停盤他都不怕耶現在主意都這麼橫你知道嗎我常常看到這種哇 都不刪了
但是如果他刪單代表後面有鬼
對不對
刪單就假的
就假的
他今天就是不會漲停
所以他其實開盤有漲
但是就巴拉巴拉拉肚子
你看他開盤
開盤就是23塊嘛
對
那後來昨天就收很低
昨天的案例
所以小哥說有去對他下手
其實是空他對不對
空他
这种这个戳涨停
然后呢
没有开涨停的
通常都是要出货
这种就叫做骗婚骨
骗婚
就是要试用一下
试婚都很表现良好
试到最后一刻
试到最后软了
没有结婚证书盖下去
就变家暴了
变梅栋桃
对
骗婚骨
深一点点
对
我们是写分点进出
是写前15大分点
前十五大分点
没有针对哪一个分点
因为听说有黑衣人真的盯上
没有啦
我们没有针对哪一个分点
前十五大分点
我们把它全部加起来
那你可以一看就知道
之前前十五大分点也都是葛日聪
你可以看到大买就变黑
红黑红黑红黑红黑
还没有黑黑红
黑红是上次的梗
大红之后就大黑
那大红之后呢
红K嘛
大黑之后就容易黑K
所以里面是短线客
那隔天就想跑了
隔天就想跑了
很短
现在股票你要做短一点
做厂很恐怖的
当初防疫的时候
他也跟着涨
后来他主力都一直在出货
他没有做那么多口罩
所以他是四戳
涨停到最后一刻
抽单
然后又看到隔日冲的主力在里面
所以就没有了
他就那天就跌了
除了他还有别人吗
还有啊
被骗昏的不止一个人
很多啦
这个台股啊
应该说股票市场
十个有九个在骗
十个九个是渣男
渣男
一个在干嘛你知道吗
在训练
一个在训练
一个不小心睡过头
被戳成胶了
九个渣男
一个在训练变成渣男
来看另外一个
这更惨
对
试戳吓死人
也是一路都是
58.8
锁涨停
这个还锁不住
锁住的话
你会看到买价是58.8
因为这个要卖的人太多了
要卖的人太多了
所以试错吓死人
涨10%
8.5%涨10%给你看
那前天也涨停
所以锁不住
是不是也是一个观察重点
你这边卖价都是红的
可是事实上一堆人
对
那锁不住
没动头
好
收不到
开盘呢
秋西郎
很严重
跌8%
对
你看昨天开盘跌8%
再开在这里
开在这边
这个往下刹
才刹到跌停
刚刚那个好歹
还先拉一下再下去
对
它这没有
开盘就笑死了
直接跌下去
对
所以这种
你开盘去买
也蛮危险的
因为就直接被灌下去了
完全没有生还的空间了
但是刚刚有讲
涨停也是有人可以续涨的
有的
有的是真的
真的很厉害
所以股市还是有
存情男人好不好
真的
说10%就10%
对
来看昨天的达冷
达冷
昨天的试戳6.47块
对
一路锁到哪边
戳到57秒
8.59分57秒
我们都说
其实试戳
什么时候最准你知道吗
什么时候最准
8.59分59秒最准
那就看开盘就好啦
对
恼怒
57秒也很準啦
因為他5秒中一次嘛
所以小哥在這3秒就決定他會漲停了
57秒
真的說沒有抽
第一盤就成交
943張
之後呢
之後就怎麼樣
之後成交都是由市價優先
排對了
這是今年改的規則
很討厭
怎麼說
我們以前呢
在玩這種漲停板的
在追漲停的時候
你开盘那一刻没有追到
盘中还有四个半小时的时间
就一直挂一直挂
你就等着嘛
四个半小时时间都有机会
那现在这种没有
现在这种是开盘你没有成交到
你可以删单了
赶快删
因为等到市价买完了
换你买到就要开始跌了
有问题嘛
才会那么多人卖出来
对 没错
所以这个是试错涨停
开盘也真的涨停的
真的涨停的
这种就真的强的
真的强的
所以它也有主力筹码在里面吗
有
这种我们看过很多
很多种
很多次了
那这种是怎样
它在盘整的时候
你看盘整的时候
第一根
这盘整的时候第一根主力是大卖的
对
这种看过很多次
第一根主力大卖后面还是上
那下不过是胸罩乙线吗
没有
胸罩乙线是高档
他这个不算高档
盘整
这是盘整的大豪K
都已经要攻了
主力为什么要大卖呢
这个现在主力很厉害
对
他有主力
大家都会看丑马K
我为了让自己不要变成前15名
对
我有什么方法
我就买到16名以后
所以是小哥逼他这样做的
你这个幕后的黑手
应该说
当一个软体越来越多人看的时候
就会导致有些阻力会规避这个软体
那这个是阻力分散
所以理财答案秀也算是凶手之一
对
我们这个点域太高了
我看现在两天都破10万
所以我们今天做一个比较冷门的
我们做试错就想把点域率收敛一下
收敛一下
好 后面就一直涨
阻力又开始买
那反过来咧
我们刚才都讲涨的
涨的我现在懂了
能够硬到最后一刻的
他就是真男人
对
开盘前三秒软掉的
就是来骗婚
来骗婚的
对
最后一刻软了
骗婚的
好
这个来看
这个试错下跌的
下跌
这也常看到
有的甚至就跌停板去了
对
那试错下跌
我们就检查看主力筹码
对
主力还在买的
是
有可能会压低吃货
反而要乐观吗
对
反而要乐观
好
那下跌
跌停板跟下跌
有没有不同的含义呢
一般来讲
这个试戳你要让它到跌停
有时候会有一些限制
什么样的限制
你买股票容易嘛
可是你试戳要卖股票
第一个你要用挂现卖
你挂卷卷可能没那么多卷
要挂现卷才可以
有时候又停止农卷
所以试戳让它下跌比较难一点
比较难
比较难一点
除了它可以先卖
或是这个阻力
它的额度很高
才跟它下跌
但我还真是有看过
很多啊
对 就是试错是跌停板的
会比涨停板来得少很多
少很多
涨停板的每天都很多
这边我不晓得我们制住人
就不肯再做第二条
试错下跌
检查主力筹码
没有就继续跌吗
没有
没有可能就真的跌了
对啊
没有好不好
这边有个没有
那可能真的跌
不要管它了好不好
对
好
来吧
这个我就设计了一个东西
这个设计呢
我平常早上大概看一下
小哥你知道我们很怕这种东西吗
正价差比
还比耶
还逆价差
还比
我还知道正价差逆价差还要比
比呢
我们是讲那个涨幅之比
还要比涨幅
对
不然正价差一般来讲是比几块
对啊
比几块
大力光10块
对
跟你友达1块
比起来友达1块差很多
比率
一两块这不够
正价差比
怎么比呢
怎么会想要来比这个
正价差代表期货贵
个股期
因为现在在讲个股
个股的期货
其实反映它的价格比较贵
现货便宜
现货价是跟它有背离的
等于是有比它低
对不对
这叫正价差比
其实来说
像这张图8点50分的时候结的
对
8点50分
那你想一下
期货已经不能戳了
期货已经开盘了
對 期貨已經開盤了
真金白銀在成交了
所以期貨是真的了
期貨真的了
所以期貨是真的喔
期貨貴是真的喔
所以8點50分來看這個事情
期貨真的喔
對
限貨便宜
限貨還在搓
限貨可能假的
對
好 等一下看期貨真的成交限貨被搓低對代表什麼意思啊有人要壓低吃貨對 趙華你好聰明很聰明你也在考我
沒有
有人偷偷的考
不要被發現
逆價差比
期貨開盤了
期貨的價格比較便宜
真的成交了
期貨真的成交了
現貨貴
還在戳戳戳戳高
現貨戳高
有人在幹嘛
想要到货
对 很聪明
大家都转了一圈
没关系 教你看
红色有人要吃
绿色有人要出
以这个文贸来说
因为它期货已经开盘了
现货还在戳
期货目前的价格是比它多
7.79
这应该是%吧
对
7.79%
期货比较高
现货比较低
所以这一档如果它还在那边戳低的话
就代表有人想吃货了
对 想吃货
文贸有人想吃货
对
汉堂有人想到出货
出货
这样一看就清楚了
很简单
好 这小哥设计的啦
外面不容易找
对啊 制作人每次都说
小哥那外面有没有类似软体
有的话我就一定跟你讲
对 你要造福一下用其他网站的人
那目前就没有
这个功能没有 但这功能很好用
对 很好用
你也可以自己设计啊
你可以用一次的表自己弄
也可以
我是教你概念
可以自己弄
这个工具很好用
好 来看一下这个文帽
举例说明
正价差
这个期货搓在这边
期货在那边成交
现货搓更低
后面就涨上来
就涨上去
这昨天的图
所以就证实了这个价差比
正价差一定要注意
试搓开低
但是期货其实价格比它高的话
应该开盘会往上跑
对 没错
好
那我们来看
这个主力
主力呢
这个最近有在买
对
那它就真的往上搓了
它还配合刚才看
主力也在买
所以就等于各方条件都齐备了
所以它会往上涨
那还有试戳跌停
但最近你也知道有一些生计股
最近很有名的
试戳呢
因为赵华把两党
母子生计股放在一起
他们就一起是红块块
变成每天都是绿块块
每天都一条线
天国一灰
很有名的
来看一下这个试戳跌停
开盘跌停
我们看一下
这个因为它被处置
这就是我讲的那个快快
中天
一条线
每天用一条线
还是储置股呢
储置股
它20分钟
所以试错只有两盘
对
8点半一次
8点51次
对
然后我们看一下
在试错的时候
你只要看到
尾卖张数很多的时候
对
手上有这档股票
你要做什么事情你知道吗
赶快也挂出去吧
先卖掉再说
对因为第一盘
跌停耶
我怎么舍得跌停卖掉啦
你看一下
它会不会反弹
我等一等嘛
你等一等
你它每天跳空一字線跌停
隔天就是繼續跌停
那你假如這個先賣掉
以後再買回來就好了
你說等它跌夠
你真的很喜歡它的話
不是 我哪知道什麼時候跌夠啊
哪知道什麼時候
我現在如果賣了
它剛好又漲怎麼辦
很簡單
你就看試抽量有沒有變很大
試抽量有沒有變很大
很大嗎
你看這個試抽還300多張不夠大
有一天試抽
假如是1萬張
那尾卖剩下2000张
那今天就要开了
我懂你的意思
试错的买单如果非常非常大
那就可能是真的会把它买开
那真的啊
但是现在根本没有人要买
现在没有啊
现在每天都跳光一支线啊
对啊 今天也是一支线
无量跌停的状态
对 它无量跌停
所以这个就是试错开盘跌停是真的
因为它不能限股卖出
它不能限股卖出
很麻烦的
但是这边我要帮小股民
因为有人在理财大人秀
这边留言说
最近很多热门股
不管是不是试错跌停
开盘跌停
也可能盘中跌停所住
他觉得那该怎么做
就像刚刚赵华讲的
他盘中搞不好本来好好的
就偏偏杀一个跌停
那就等啊
通常这样讲
这个跌停的话
你不要去买
不要去买是不是
跌停不要去买
对
有的人想说
那我跌停买了
涨停我就不是赚22%吗
对啊
你不要这样想
为什么我们要看
你看这里也有人这样想
你看
你看这里看到18000张
很多人去买跌停板这样子
不知道他在想什麼
應該是成交了嘛
那我大買個四張好了
看能不能把它敲開
小子人
他在賭隔天可能會打開
你賭隔天會打開
你可以更尾盤的時候去買
更尾盤的時候再看看
通常你看這18000張
這些人
他可能每天
明天要繼續掛賣出
所以看到熱門股跌停
先不要去搶
但反過來
他手上是熱門股跌停呢
手上熱門股跌停
第一根你就要趕快去掛了
第一根一定要把它掛出去
那第二根呢
掛
第一根跟第二根都要搞它掛卖出
第三根第四根就不一定了
那绝大多数都爆到第三根第四根了
那绝大多数都是怎么样
绝大多数人都是在
跌停打开那一天卖掉的
跌停打开那一天
好不容易可以卖得掉啦
但那天反而要买
那天反而要买
一开始大家会有点害怕
我觉得很难耶
人的心态很难
其实你就看量就可以了
你只要看量
这个量没出
你看到几百张
明天继续跌停
这量一有出
它就会打开
所以还是要看
而且从试出
其实可以看得到
看得出来
但是像这个的话
我们一样可以看筹码
对不对
看到底谁在卖
对
主力一定要趁涨的时候卖
等到开始跌停的时候
主力就出不掉
所以你看到
这个往上涨的时候
其实主力已经在出过了
主力其实一路在出
而且这边还
這邊像小哥有點講
他在起掌前
這邊還大叔
是為了躲你的手碼
這邊要分批出
對
因為他不分批出
等到一藏黑
就出不掉了
因為後面這個都賞物追的
那這種
我們叫做戰板
登山的那個戰板
一階一階的上去
你看到一階一階
你就知道會一階一階下來
所以通常你買到的時候
一挑一隻線你是買不到的
通常你買到的時候
就是一階階下來的時候
天價一階階下來的時候
所以漲停打開翻黑不要亂碰
然後跌停下來打開不要亂賣
你假如跌停下來
可能會賣在一個阿呆股
不知道阿呆股在哪裡
我們來看另外一檔
合一
可是這不就是跟中天是同名的嗎
綁在一起
因為他們母子公司
好
來看這個合一
這個試戳一開盤
389張
不够多
那个伪卖还有7000多张
所以代表说
它今天还是容易跌停
只要这个没分盘的成交
没有爆量
它就是会锁死
锁死的话
明天又有可能会跌停
所以任何买进
都是不治的行为
所以你看这边有一张两张
不知道他在想什么
要等他的买卖量
平均过来对不对
对 你一定要等到
这个伪卖账数变少
成交账数变多
你去买才有意义
不然你去买
都是为了怎么样
拯救里面的人
所以我这边
因为我自己有在看试错
所以其实这有点像是
小股民的很像是赵华自己
我自己有一个疑问
因为我每天早上在股东前朝
为了要去盯开盘
我发现期货的试错很准
对 期货太准了
像他说期货试错涨百点
开盘就给你涨一百点
真的超奇妙的
期货试错跌百点
那不得了了
就真的跌远
我觉得像我手上
如果没有期货部位
我是有现股部位
我至少知道
我今天的现股
可能是红还是跌
对
为什么
因为有控盘者在后面
控盘者
控盘者可能是外资
或是黑手
对
他是利用期货跟一些全资股
是
来做控盘
对
所以当期货大涨的时候
他们也有一些城市交易
期货大涨
那你今天台积电
要买到哪个价格
台积电要买到那个价格
期货才会涨那么多
对啊
这台指期啦
只是台指期
所以期货试错通常是准的
因为有控盘者
跟个股试错不一样
没错
我们常看到
例如说
这个大盘已经很准了
像台积电的个股期也超准
台积电个股期开哪里
股票就开哪里
所以很大型很大型的全资股
已经跟大盘一样了
对
然后再来就是
这个小哥其实刚刚有稍微解答
我從8.30看 8.40看 8.50看 8.59看
它的價格一直在起伏
我是看幾點的最有參考價值
很多人想說
小哥會不會講什麼很神秘的數字8.32分56秒 沒有最有參考價值呢 8.59分59秒那就開盤了還不是一樣就剛剛講就開盤才有價值就是要等到那一刻
所以不是德政
那根本不是德政啊
就是讓一些大陸來玩
證交所你很久沒有來找
我們理財達人秀的證交所
如果你有德政
記得要找理財達人秀
要不然我會告訴你
這不像德政喔
好 跟證交所喊話一下
久久沒來光顧了
好 那第三个
第三个也是
你刚刚讲到台积电
也一半解答了
我有曾经看过台积电试戳
可能跌两块 跌一块
接近开盘还是跌的是绿的
但开盘就一下开高六块钱
全职股试戳
我想说我都已经是台积电了
还有人要玩
那也可能
其实你看全职股
你可以看一个东西比较准
看期货就好了
你只要看到全职股试戳下跌
期货上涨
那开盘就上涨
所以我就应该去抢它吗
对
小哥其实也对量很有观察
刚刚讲说
其实例如他跌停
反正挂卖单的量那么多
买单只有一点点的时候
他是不可能敲开的
可是刚刚小哥有提醒
量其实是试戳盘
我们要注意的一件事
它也代表了真跟假
很重要啊
来看这个
我们会讲
伤数越少
对
像刚刚我们讲说
要到59分59秒嘛
对啊
那就等开盘就好了
每天看到心脏变发
对
因为等到最后那一秒
要决定到底要不要买看
那其实我们在试戳的中间
我们会看到它的量的变化
这招绝招
绝招 大绝招
大绝招
外面要卖三万八的
今天免费又卖出去
赚到三万八咯
今天还在举的
好不好 看试戳赚到三万八
那这个量呢
各位看一下
这一千多张
这变九百多张
这变七百多张
对 它还是一路有抽单
张数越少
越接近真实的价格
你说留下来的张数是不是
对 就是成交的张数
这是试错的量
那这个代表有人抽单
抽单他就把假的给抽掉
假单一直在变少中
张数越少越接近
然后到了这边
其实他的单量已经没什么变化了
对 你要继续往下看
我只是说
韩中你只要看到
这个变少
那这个真的 这个假的
那代表有人试图往上戳
试图往上戳
是为了干嘛
出货
这边已经面平盘了
对
然后买价是变绿的
这又是一个开盘
盘前试戳
吓死人
对
开盘笑死人
所以买单其实都抽掉了
对
所以单数越少
反而越靠近真实价格
对 没错
好
那有人会想
小哥我学了这一招之后
以后我做交易
无往不利吗
我特别要拿一张图给你看
好
它是戳掌停开低
那戳掌停開廳
那就是要往下殺嗎
戳掌停開廳就是
剛剛我們有教的
他在右空你
他要出貨嘛
對 他要到貨給你
我跟你講
這檔股票我有去研究
對
他戳掌停真的是隔衝去戳的
隔衝也真的賣掉了
那不就符合你講的
試戳掌停裡面程碼是隔日充
他應該拉一下就掉下去了
對啊
結果為什麼又拉到掌停了
因為又有另外一派人進去了
我要怎麼知道
另外一派人為什麼要進去
沒辦法
太難了
所以有些股票我们这样做
你研究完之后
你的胜率会到达八成
但不代表你百分之百会对
因为股票是众人决定的
所以小哥有可能
这一档本来想去try它
但是就被拉上去
那自己就要停损掉
自己就要停损掉
也是有可能会错啦
或是有主力
它是拉高出货的
那你拉高出货
拉高你空
出货你要赶快补
但是这种你会空得很吃力
所以除非它有非常多隔日虫
不然一般涨停百分比股票
我们是不会碰
好
所以主力也会接棒的
对 没错
小哥刚才讲这段意思是说
交给你一个高胜率的东西
一许80%你照着做会准
可是当你发现有异常
说你不要来骂说
都不准什么什么
因为还是有20%
会有意外嘛
那就记得你的停损一定要做好
停损要快
因为你做得越短
你的胜率就不每样越高
所以当遇到不符合预期的
你还是要出掉
就公开跑掉了
所以我们今天教很多东西
一个试错有这么多学问
来做个小总结
来 结论
来 第一个
极小量或极大量
刚刚有讲说极小量
没有什么人在玩的
对啊 你看试错一张
那真的要卖的
一张是真的
你看到300张 500张 5000张
都可能是假的
几百张到几千张
还有可能是假的
几张反而是真的
一两张真的
那十几万张真的
十几万张真的太看好了
非抢到不可或非卖掉不可
因为你十几万张
一般人没办法挂那么多
或是一般人你去删十几万张
证交所都去找你
怎么可能有十几万张可以挂
证交所会找
你试错挂太多删太多
证交所会去盯你的
不是 证交所不是觉得是德政吗
你不能来玩其他散户嘛
还是在玩啊
所以我怀疑有些人
他们是一群人在玩
对
多人运动
好
这个
有大量格冲戳涨停
是为了出货
开高可别追
对 很多戳涨停都是为了出货的
第三呢
无法现股卖出的股票戳跌停
对
像中天啊 合一啊
没办法现股卖出啊
就進入到分盤交易了
分盤交易 錯跌停
那真的是跌停了
真的是跌停了
高榔時要趕快賣
容易好幾根
就是分盤交易
今年腰股特別多
所以大家會發現
很多股票很快就進入到
處置股票
就等於可能20分鐘
才能交易一次
那這種公司有時候
你會覺得好像在裡面
也是關著標得很開心
可是如果這樣的股票
一旦所跌停是很麻煩的
所以小哥發現
如果這個試錯就跌停
你真的還是能跑就跑
對不對
第一根趕快跑
不然到后面你会很难过
好
因为每天解停
所以呢
大家都有订阅我们的精英班
对不对
那大家都知道
还有一个东西叫荣耀班
那很多人会问说
荣耀班跟精英班有什么不一样
荣耀班就是我们
凹到什么
小哥刚刚已经讲
今天讲试错有三万八的秘密
他在外面要收钱的
已经免费交给你
没做那么贵
小哥刚才试错骗到造化了
其实是一万八
抽38000
试错38000
然后所以小哥之后
也会加入我们
荣耀班教学的内容
不是只有直播了
所以今天我们不好意思
留一首留什么呢
大家可以看一下
加码演出
这种试错的情况
小哥100%会去挂
而且100%会赚到钱
但是在现在不能讲
请大家订阅我们荣耀班
我们会在荣耀班
把纸撕下来公布答案
什么样的情况
试出100%要去挂
100%会赚钱
好那这边呢
赵华来谢谢
来加入我们
就是付费会员的朋友们
就赵华注意到你咯
好这位是
其实这位的头像
我真的觉得很眼熟
因为赵华以前也有在骑单车
他叫龙叔
然后放了一个骑单车的头像
他说感谢理财单秀
赵华和各位大师
当然包含小哥啦
让我这个新手认识股票怎么入手
但他入手是写玩不要玩
入手投資好不好
然後這個叫Jason
他說他是理財達人秀的忠實粉絲
感謝老師們的教學
真的收穫滿滿
也超喜歡趙華的主持風格
讓整個節目一直都很精彩
跟充實跟充滿了色彩
對不對
張志祥
張志祥你常來
志祥是我們的老朋友
小哥的嘿嘿嘿就劍紅
害我不小心把水都噴出來了
不知道是什麼水
是口水
如果鍵盤壞掉
小哥要陪我
他說這集又學到很實用的技能囉
希望這個節目繼續照顧我們
那趙華也非常的謝謝你囉
好 今天非常謝謝小哥
一個試戳有這麼多的學問
我相信看一遍也是學不起來的
要看兩遍 看三遍
那如果想要知道小哥暗扛的一些
百分百勝率的秘技
記得記得訂閱我們的榮耀班
我們有精英班跟榮耀班
要選榮耀班喔
那今天非常謝謝小哥
來錄我們的理財答案秀的
歌有仇必報
我們下次再見囉
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜